the College of psychologists a bunch of
people put in power by the government
basically is threatening to take my
Dad's psychology license because he's
been criticizing the government he's
getting investigated because of tweets
he's tweeted personal tweets opinions
things he said on Joe Rogan they're
requiring him to do media retraining
that he pays 225 dollars an hour for for
an unspecified amount of time and then
at the end of that training they decide
whether or not he's learned anything and
whether he can continue being a
psychologist I'm not entirely sure what
to do here other than tell people about
what's going on but maybe complaining
back at them is appropriate you can go
to the link I'm going to link it below
and you can enter in a complaint about
the college itself and the people
running it because they're bullying and
harassing my family so I don't know
where the protection there is it's a
serious War out there it's crazy and we
could use some help here